violence appears to be on the rise in
mexico
attacks against businesses in states
like jalisco and guanajuato
a rampage that left at least nine dead
in sioux juarez
and a wave of violence in the city of
tijuana all in the span of a week has
left many wondering what exactly is
going on
we know so far is that what we have is a
series of unrelated events that have
been very close to each other uh
within within within a single week um
those uh
each one of those has a different logic
each one of those has a different
trigger
the attacks have spurred the mexican
government to deploy national guard
troops to states like baja california
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador acknowledged the violence but
says it has been blown out of proportion
by his political opponents
everyone relaxed there is governability
there is stability at the same time
there is an interest from my adversaries
the conservatives to magnify things and
carry out sensationalist journalism
violence and vandalism from criminal
militias in mexico are not a new
phenomenon
because security analysts say there are
rarely any consequences
impunity is rampant
criminal investigations are are few and
far
far between
and they are what
you don't have a strong
you don't have strong investigative
capabilities that can
uh
increase the likelihood that anyone
involved in this type of events will be
punished
mexico's government has not announced
any new plans to change the country's
security strategy
the policy seems instead to be to
intensify the existing one with
increased military style policing in
regions where cartels operate
while experts in mexico say these latest
instances of cartel related violence
don't appear to be connected the picture
that's emerging is of a country where
despite more boots on the ground
security forces are still losing ground
to criminal organizations
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city